every day whenever I hear that buzzer it
just gets your blood flowing your heart
pumping and you just take off at a
sprint you really don't know what you're
getting into and so you can see the fire
you're jumping out of a plane that's
always and they induce a little bit of
adrenaline
there are a few professions that
captivate us quite like smokejumping and
I'm speaking with a woman who has been
doing it for over a decade
my name is Ramona B yuca and I am mama
called smokejumper & McCall Idaho she
jumps out of planes and into forest
fires her job is to contain them this is
what a day for a smokejumper is like we
find a twin otter with the door off
we're all wearing earplugs and
everyone's kind of in their own world at
that point and this flight can take up
to a few hours but it becomes clear when
they're close usually you smell that
smoke since that piney wood burning
smell you know that it's go time you get
in the door and that's when you really
gotta focus your heart is pounding and
then they slap you and your shoulder and
I don't even really think about it I
just go out of the planes I try not to
look at the ground or the fire at that
point you're just super focused
and that was just part one now they
fight the fire I've been to so many
forest fires and yeah every jump is
different but it's not a profession for
everyone that adrenaline is something
that that's a big part of keeping me
coming back I do stop and think wow I am
really lucky to be in this job
[Music]